fine sir thank you how can we help you
okay
I just about a month ago got diagnosed
with type 2 diabetes and I deal with
irritable bowel with diarrhea and I'm
about five nine 130 pounds I was about
145 a few months ago and they put me on
metformin twice a day 500 milligrams and
glamour pride four milligrams they
dropped it down to two because in about
oh four days four or five days I was
under a hundred his vocal and glucose
run test and then sure if getting your
packet two weeks later that liquid won
the health impact 2.0 liquid and then
sweeties and I dropped down to 70 I just
want to make sure you know cuz I deal
with irritable bowel and I reapply cat I
want to make sure I'm getting absorbed
properly which we need to take do I take
them with food can I take them together
sure I'm just gonna figure out yeah well
let's get started by obviously you're
having some success that's very very
good
see 135 pounds five foot nine so you're
thin okay your old vowel syndrome
Charmaine are you there mmm-hmm okay
what is what is Jason's basic underlying
problem here he has a gluten intolerance
and that's why he got probably gathered
the other problems because of the gluten
intolerance yep he got the IBS or bowel
syndrome which is a contact enteritis
sensitivities gluten sweet butter and
oats in all its forms see type-2
diabetes is a caused by deficiency
actually the single nutrient been going
for 83 years it's not genetic indeed for
easily prevented easily is supported
healthy easy to support a healthy blood
sugar so that your body can heal itself
and have proper
sugar and carbohydrate metabolism
cellular level and so would you
what would you give Jason in addition to
the diet no no the bad for haikus
processed meats are also gluten and no
sugar and so what would you give him and
a hundred thirty pounds to deal with a
type 2 diabetes
any joint or bone problems here Jason no
no other help from okay okay good that's
easy then okay what would you give him
as a supplement program to support his
body's ability to save itself for his
issues I would give him a one healthy
blood sugar pack and the vitamin d3 and
obviously he's gotta be on a gluten-free
diet okay and I would get an extra
bottle of that sweetie so you could take
320 a day and again no sugar no fried
business process needs oil
IBS will go away because as caused by
that that it was called two weeks and
four weeks we'll walk you through this
you're gonna be a good man